slugs boy slugs girl slugs tran slugs uh
confused slugs known slugs slimy slush
slimy slugs especially
real slugs yeah
slugs slugs missing limbs slugs with um
hemorrhoids we're finally doing the real
deal live stream show and
it's there's concerns there's legal
concerns
there's emotional concerns try to sue me
you guys wednesday march 30th at 6 00 pm
pacific time we are streaming live from
this room and it's going to be chaotic
and we want you to get tickets at
momenthouse.com
trash tuesday this is a once in a
lifetime opportunity who the f knows
what is going to happen
annie has threatened to
bring a cardboard cutout of a certain
type of vehicle we don't know
oh god
get your tickets at momenthouse.com
trash tuesday because once this is gone
it's gone you guys that's wednesday
march 30th 6 p.m see you guys there
we're scared
hey guys it's esther i'll be in helium
comedy club in philadelphia april 1st
through 2nd
april 6th american comedy club san diego
15 through 16th of april uh cap city
comedy in austin then i'll be in
brooklyn d.c my hometown of chicago
minneapolis and indianapolis many more
coming soon
estranged.com hey slugs i'm having the
greatest time on the road i'm not just
saying that come i'm signing scrotums
i've now learned to have them hold them
hold them taut batwing it and you can
actually see the full signature and i've
never felt more powerful i'm signing
breasts i'm we're having a wonderful
time on the road the meet and greets are
my dream come true
i can't wait to see you guys in san
francisco april 15th and 16th syracuse
new york the end of april san jose
california
in the beginning of may i'll be in back
in florida in dania beach
may 12-14 i'm gonna be in burbank austin
texas i'm gonna be in a million other
places please go to andyletterman.com
shows come see me it's a whole vibe you
can't miss it
i want to know this your dad um had
baseball cards and now you've taken over
oh no he ran a baseball card store since
1989. yeah like old school brick and
mortar yeah and she like took it and
moved it packed it up and moved it to
largemouth new york i spent months
cleaning a hoarding situation by myself
plus years of hoarding i learned also
how to learn a new business i'm not like
i'm not like a sports
girl sometimes sometimes a customer will
come in and ask me for a card and i will
like whisper quietly um
what sport do they play
remember
in the process of you like um doing this
with a shop like did you get to know
your dad a little bit better yes exactly
that was like the comforting part
because my dad wrote a lot of stuff like
he would just like sit in the store and
i guess like if a business was slow he
would like write a poem or like write a
spoof of a song he made up like game
shows making fun of his friends because
my dad legit funniest person i've ever
met and like you know being a
professional comedian that says a lot
but he's the reason that i'm even funny
at all he would tell stories about his
customers at the dinner table growing up
that were so funny that i would have to
excuse myself from the table because i
would i was gonna choke and like i don't
know if you ever laugh to laugh that you
physically you have to like roll like
get on the ground and roll it out of
your body because you think the laugh is
going to kill you that is the type of
lap like no one's made me laugh like
that
ever except for my dad and he the
baseball card business specifically
uh
had a lot of
crazy characters in it so through our
mutual friend who works at the shop he's
told me so much about how like these
people will come out of the woodwork who
are looking for your dad yeah and you
guys don't know what to do like who are
like i have this maybe like and if maybe
like they have like a side deal with
your dad and they want that side
discount still and you guys have to be
like slow down buddy yeah there's a very
old man who uh who i refer to as father
time just long beard
comes in with like a cane made of a tree
trunk and a gentle soul but you know the
business was very different even a
couple of years ago so my dad was doing
things like completing sets of cards uh
but there's not a lot of money in that
like you really want to like move full
boxes of product now and you know peop
you know pl uh sell raw cards of like
very valuable players but you know
there's also uh like a fun sense in like
completing a set of cards i i i'm trying
to like put it in words that you
everyone will understand if they don't
understand the card business if someone
was
tagged or caught for steroid use does
the value of their card oh good question
um go down over time that's like a barry
bond say for instance right that you
know what honestly i don't know the
official answer to that because
sometimes
doing something quote unquote bad can
actually make the value go up
um there are definitely questions about
people who have done like sexually
offensive things that tends to make the
value of the card go down which is like
yeah that's positive
that is progress yeah wow but like for
pokemon i know the answer a little bit
more as it relates to pokemon cards
because we also sell those and so like
pokemon has a lot of um
cards that aren't printed anymore
because they're things that were
considered like racist in america and
those actually went up in value because
they stopped printing them so they're
very rare
but like you have to hide them you know
because it's like well you know we have
them but it's like i don't condone that
america always buys the thing that
expires because it's racist yes we had
that in college i went to university of
illinois in champaign and the well one
of the years i was there was the last
year that they were allowed to do the
chief logo
and everyone was buying them up like
crazy i'm like for why
this is so weird i gotta get it put it
on your wall and go that's you can't
sell it anymore because it's racist but
i have it yeah
yeah it was actually like 12 year old
boys who inform me to this i learned so
much from the neighborhood
boys about pokemon which was really nice
of them to share their knowledge with me
yeah on opening day i went to her store
and i was following all the kids around
like how's your dad single what's up
like there's
dads in that town there are hot dabs i
feel like divorce dads are my
demographic shout out largemont new york
whoa that's such a good way to maybe
find like a hot older guy yeah oh yeah
it's like like and also it's unheard of
for like a woman to be a baseball card
store owner so people wear seven
comedians oh yeah
you could tell people just sometimes
come in like there's this
i hope he doesn't watch this is this one
customer who roams around
drunk um but like like lightly drunk he
doesn't he's having fun yeah no it's
like you it's not the kind of guy you
would feel sad for it's just like you
know he made himself drunk and he's fine
with it and he knows um and he'll come
in
and you could tell he'll just like buy
like a a cup but it's he's obviously
just there to talk to me
because he just who just needs to come
in to get no he's married
to buy a single cup from a baseball card
store like that's weird
i i i think it's okay that you're saying
this because i feel like i'm that guy
who will buy the cup just to talk to
someone like i love i love lingering and
loitering in a store
if they're if skims opens brick and
mortar stores i will be gonna be roaming
the skins i will be roaming i will
instead of drunk i'll be high on edibles
oh my god and i'll just be touching
everything they'll have to refold it
they'll hate me there do you like yes
yes i've worked retail for years oh
one eye piles
i would side-eye the [ __ ] out of you i
would look at those dirty little fingers
like you know what size you are you
don't need to see the whole i try to be
so careful in a retail store i worked
retail but i worked shoes so there was
no folder which retail did you work at i
worked at abercrombie okay that was a
pretty organized one i worked at forever
21.
oh why are we even trying they're all
going to get [ __ ] up anyway yeah just
throw everything in a box let people
know
no i will say my mom
like
i she always made me hang everything up
after i tried it on like she was very
strict oh i'm that person that if you're
rude and i see that you're not refolding
things and you ask me for a size i will
go back there take a bite out of my
burger
look around for about two minutes come
back and say sorry we don't have it oh
that's like that [ __ ]
yeah
yeah because it's like you're being rude
i have to now refold an entire stack of
polos right that's not that easy long
sleeved ones where there's an extra
folding because you have the square that
was like like the you know what i mean
like the cut out shape for the fold for
the men's shirts but i'm a master air
folder so i the flick of the wrist i got
this down is that an official title or
you give that to yourself
the girl that can air fold
you just watch them like how do you do
that you don't even need them i want to
show you guys a picture of my t-shirt
stack at home it's pretty impressive the
sides are all lined up yeah it's the
only thing my mom's proud of the only
the way you fold your shirts
she has ocd and it's ocd and symmetry
okay so it's the symmetrical face i
that's actually thank you but that's not
true i have the most asymmetrical face
oh my god
okay corinne also has a very no you're a
symmetrical am i am i seeing weird one
van damme you know like jean-claude van
damme yeah yeah my dad always used to
say i had his one eye was smaller than
me oh that thanks dad yeah
but i was like keeping me humble
i was like it literally doesn't matter
you're dropped at gorgeous yeah yeah
yeah you're hot
is that a tattoo idea jean-claude van
gaal on you john claw van d
yes oh
that one oh you're welcome
but right under my wonky eye yeah i
cannot tell it's not wonky
in photos where it's one of what i'll be
like this like all the time is it bad
that my dad used to call me an andrew
cunanan the guy who killed he's half
filipino what he is yeah isn't it andrew
cunanan
you know whatever we are not trying to
correct the name of a murderer your dad
calls you a murderer what a reference
esther because he's like a gay
uh mad lover and i got you know gay
murderer because i was caught
downloading naked pictures of women and
so they called they made fun of me and
called me andrew cunanan anyway like on
every episode of this something about
your lesbianism comes
i don't like your parents bullied you
and you're like oh
all right esther darren chris played him
really yeah oh he's so hot so this is a
good thing so he's half filipino and
darren chris's mom is from my island are
you serious
yes yes you guys started without me i'm
just kidding
oh i like this like they made us they
made us i'm sorry oh i yell at you
how are you how are you
hi
oh my goodness look at this
my neck weakness wait do you have a neck
injury today yeah i never know what day
we have it esther's talking about how
she her dad called her andrew kanan
the guy who killed um um gianni yeah
versace
what does he look can we pull out the
picture no it's not based on looks that
i was called him it's because she was
downloading a picture of boobs of naked
women it's a gay thing again
yeah gamer again she's a gay male
murderer as a gay male murderer
i need to know more about this because i
i side with your dad always well we were
talking about things our dad called us
which i feel like you probably have some
good ones oh selfish [ __ ] yeah wow
yeah but they made me so funny
my makeup was done while driving the
tesla and um
is that i mean
did the tesla do your makeup the tesla
yeah
i was in la jolla opening for uh doug i
mean doug oh my god doug stanhope
i did that several times but he kept
calling me leaderman because we just
this was like our first time meeting
officially we've been like really yeah
we've been like talked on the phone
friends and stuff like that for a while
but um
so it was the first time we were
actually hanging out and then it ended
up being
i had my first tesla trauma what oh i
read about this on twitter yes he's live
tweeting it
doug was live tweeting it yeah he was
live chatting the experience well you
have to like you know charge them and i
oh no
it's a problem i had to find a charger
and i in the charger no no you're gonna
love it
no no you have to you know charge them
no no no
no
you know wait until but you're gonna
love this so much because there's
there's a blame situation
i love blaming okay so i know i feel so
you get so funny because it's not your
fault you get 15 seconds of blame and
then you have to be like oh i'm a grown
up
nobody does anything on purpose
okay so
we
i go to doug i go he was gonna take the
train in today we're also gonna be at
the regular comedy store
and
i know i feel rude saying it but come on
it's the good one yeah the good ones the
one people talking about even though it
is fun and they're so they're such a fun
rich white
it's like irvine kind of right yeah
they're just
they're funny i remember when we did the
irvine improv we're like oh you voted
for him we did it the day trump got
elected
and then everyone was like i was like
you guys it sucks right and they're like
no we're i did i did the i know it's so
weird it was such a different
experiences but i did the i did the la
jolla comedy story the night that
kyle rittenhouse got off oh guys
congratulations
i go you say written you say hello
so anyways
because it's like a christmas town which
is like so we should bring you there and
see what they do
they put her to work i love wait why is
it a christmas town they it's just
they're obsessed with christmas dr seuss
is from there and that's why you wrote
the grin that's cool
i did say those trees on our airbnb
block were very doctors seussical yeah
yeah i like your guys rental by the way
good choice christina's a car girl yeah
wait so what happened with the tesla
okay so i go so i go to doug i go you
can ride on the train tomorrow or you
can ride with me tonight and he goes can
i i let him smoke in the tesla and
everything i was looking at smoking the
tesla wow that's the only tesla nelly
you could smoke yeah
shuts the car off
but so i had to charge it and the
charger that they sent me to was not an
actual
tesla supercharger so i go to this hotel
i have to go in this guy shows me he was
a fan
hello daniel from the hyatt
um
doug stand open the car he goes no way
um so then we go to this charger and it
needs an adapter that my car has
so i go to just casually get the adapter
it's not gonna be a problem um todd
seems to have thought the adapter should
be just like outside the car for some
reason not in the car while i'm on a the
first road trip in it
so todd had attached it to the charger
at home
and never put it back in
so i called todd and i go
todd i'm [ __ ] pissed right and doug's
going yeah you know like teasing me for
being mad at him
and todd goes so todd's he's i can see
his brain working to see how it's not
his fault i mean not one moment of
accepting the responsibility goes no
well i thought we would leave it on the
charger at home so we'd have to worry
about losing it
in the car that it would never leave
that would be a weird thing and then he
goes but don't you remember you were in
a rush so you said hurry up don't wind
it all the way back up so i did tell him
to not completely put the charger away
well he had evidence
yes he did it took him a second though
it wasn't his first idea that's why i
know it is his fault because the second
one's a charm yeah he was searching for
why it wasn't
and uh but it was good so and then we
just found another one and it was fine
but it did take it took a while to find
it how long do you have to charge that
car it takes like 20 minutes or if you
have a regular if you have to do one of
the regular chargers like 14 hours so i
was like yeah todd i'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you if i missed my podcast
it was like 12 p.m last night yeah i
know it is scary because i was in a car
with a tesla when we had to find a
charger too and like it's new york so
there was even less charging stations
and of course it was like an
ex-boyfriend who was like in town truck
and she was like wanted to pick me up
and and i was like just the whole time
as we were racing to find a charger i'm
going this is why we broke up this is
why we broke up did he rent it or was it
his car it was a it
yeah but it was not his because he lives
here but yeah how many times are we
allowed to go back
i don't know the specific one or two and
ex-boyfriend in general yeah just
just in general just coming back is
never not in like not in a relationship
way but just in a in a sexual way how
many times do we get that oh that's
unlimited the limit does not exist
yeah yeah the [ __ ]
oh really it's an unlimited you have to
gauge your own
do you let emotions spill over do you
not yeah it's like if you can
compartment i'm good at compartments
that's great because then you're already
comfortable with their body you don't
you you know their body you don't you're
not going to continue
no no no you guys because i've got there
are surprises because
memory lies yes because your memory lies
to you you you you you oh like if you
think it's better it gets better and
then like oh god and i remember my i had
this one ex-boyfriend who was he was so
handsome i sure left him
oh my god we're still dating
um
[Laughter]
but he yeah i
i had remembered him as being just so
hot
and he had two he had lesbian mom so it
was like double the mommy's shoes i
forgot and my friend anja goes and he
cries you forgot he cries i was like oh
no i was already on my road trip to
irvine to go bang him
and i forgot he was so like sensitive
and i got there and you couldn't i love
i love that you were you you were
already on the road trip and you
couldn't possibly turn around no no no
esther i'm a good girl
i follow it through my promises once you
pull out
of the driveway this was one of the
experiences where i was learning how to
go you can turn around but i still was
getting hope i still was giving it hope
i'm like maybe
he'll cry it'll be hot now who knows i'm
older yeah and he just was so nervous he
couldn't get it up i was just like oh i
should have kept you hot in my head it's
true don't burst a fantasy bubble is
what i say oh yeah where it's like um
yeah that's sort of my rule if it even
if it's like a one night stand that just
happened to go very well just keep it
that way and yeah yeah let it live in
your memory let it die like when a show
ends and you're like wait we weren't
done with the seasons and yeah yeah but
let's go out on again and then you
remember let's milk it and someone hates
it right because if you get to know them
past that one night it could really just
go awry yeah so just keep those little
wait i've heard sorry i have heard from
a guy
that it and this could be wrong but i
have really like believed in this theory
for a long time that when you [ __ ] a guy
one time it actually will drive them
crazy because they'll wonder why they
never got a second chance and they'll be
like was i bad maybe i was bad and so
like does that happen when guys don't
[ __ ] you up
i am the friend who's telling me now
please come back for seconds is jacob
telling us the story
but jacob is a dog alter ego of mine
oh but of course obviously
esther has no alter ego that's female
let's just say that
kyla what do you think is that um i you
know what as much as i want to admit
that i've had a lot of one night stands
i know that that's what my face reads
i just have not had a lot of them
i do a lot of like three week
you know three weeks little mini
romances yes that's nice but i've done
it wrong
with maryland's i like that yes those
ones but i wanted to ask you about male
1 men who cry why is that your thing uh
they're just they're in touch with their
emotions i just i just like i like a guy
that's not afraid of that
and it's just like yeah i'll go there
and i'll go deep inside myself because i
feel like we're in a straight line but
not while he's deep inside you i'm no
not well we're [ __ ] if you're crying
because i have post-coital blues and
it's something that i've do cry gasms i
do so i cannot
cry
and it's weird because it's like even if
it's like a very safe situation and i'm
happy yeah my teeth my eyes well up and
i have to just it's just honestly it's
like it flies out of my eye it's just
intense emotion is it just intention
motion i i don't know but i get a
sadness
oh these crazy [ __ ] sometimes
emotions go where where they're not
supposed to oh
[Music]
you guys do you ever feel like there's
something preventing you from achieving
your goals
uh usually the seasons yeah or anything
sometimes it's
you just got the blues
that's why i love better help and why we
want people to check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday if you're watching this
show chances are you're not
you're not doing well you're not secure
you're you're learning to be accept
yourself for who you are i know who
helps you do that
better help better help is online
therapy and it's so cool because they
can match you with a therapist under 48
hours they have a journal feature so if
you're having big feelings and can't
speak to your therapist right away you
can just jot those down um i love that
it's confidential you can chat with them
on video or if you're having a really
really heavy day you can talk to them on
the phone in the dark whatever you need
they have if you don't like your the
first put on a gift mask put on a [ __ ]
mask and it's your apartment it's
confidential too anything you share is
confidential and i feel like a lot of us
don't really have that in our lives
someone where you can just say
everything right and it is very
affordable kalila used to say you were
dead inside and now you say i've been
resuscitated i have been resuscitated
thanks to better help they gave her cpr
her inside self we want you to start
living a happier life today and as a
listener you'll get 10 off your first
month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-com
trash tuesday i do recommend you getting
your appointment before the live
streaming event yeah um just have it
ready prepped and ready to go
you guys let's talk about manscaped okay
yeah let's talk let's make some
landscape plans actually because i do
actually use manscape on my
vaginal regions and
my my [ __ ]
uh well yes because they have the led
lights yeah as you can see right
yeah you can get that real good accuracy
that you need you don't have to worry
about your partner getting their arm
stuck in there for 127 hours and you
guys we're we don't mind hair we just
need you to show us that you care a
little bit by grooming a little bit you
care i care we can share manscaped are
the global leaders in men's below the
waist grooming and have forever changed
the grooming game with their amazing
performance package 4.0 inside this ball
care bundle
he'll find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
weed whacker earrings no
nose hair trimmer i'm looking for it
crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold all the goodies
so it's a really cute gift it comes with
a lot of thoughtful things and the
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer is waterproof and
like kalya said equipped with an led
light so you bet it's a major key to the
new shower routine no more mess on the
bathroom floor yeah i like todd wears
the boxers all the time and i
i always know he's clean-shaven when he
puts them on get 20 off and free
shipping with the code trash at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com spring is nature's way of
saying let's party so party on with
manscape
[Music]
wait you know what i was just you made
me think of do you have a third eye
blind song when he's like when i fell
asleep inside yeah
back to the place
he'll sleep inside you how do i get back
to that
third eye
podcast
flip this and he'll probably see it if
you tag him yeah hey baby what's up well
i love that because honestly he they're
orbiting they were at um supernova
recently corinne and i saw them we went
to the we managed to get to the front
row and i was like how am i going to
stand out to stephen jenkins you should
have said how am i going to fall asleep
like we managed to get to the front row
like it was right we just
and then at the end when he was like
behind everybody
and i took this the flashlight on your
iphone and i shined it at me this is
true because i was like everyone's
shining it over there i'm shining at me
because i wanted to see my face and but
i blinded myself and i didn't see that
he actually did look at me stephen when
you shut a light on yourself at a
concert it turns out this light singer
notices what are you doing
so funny that's a really great tip yeah
but also
she
blind
a seizure we can't have a yeah nothing
happened like travis scott yeah you know
allegedly a toxic person but i'm like of
course he is look at the listen to the
lyrics of the song if he was a
sweetheart i'd be disappointed listen we
don't think you're toxic you should
switch over to our show being your
favorite
he followed her on instagram and like
was commenting on her show
yeah and i and then i i i tagged him in
a photo on stories and goes oh i didn't
know you were there you should have told
me and i was like what would have
happened if i told you we have had sex
yeah i told you with the light in my
face you didn't see the big spotlight i
brought with me we lingered after the
concert too yeah because i was like we
had a moment oh we hung out after that
concert on the streets we did and he
didn't come out my favorite part was
when the security guard looks at
christina and goes i've been working
here for 20 years i've never seen
someone do this before
that's unique
okay so are you you're a foot out person
you you expose the feet what oh that's
right you like to blur your feet i think
they can't have them for free oh yeah
what is it though what's the foot finish
website that we're all on
yeah yeah great you look hot though i'm
like i'm excited you're doing well i'm
just so excited to have my toes out from
new york it's been cold for so long i'm
like they need to go out also like i
have a big old bunion from wearing spice
girls shoes so no one wants these these
are keep your feet these are
marshmallows these are marshall's shoes
if a guy saw him run away
an x real quick because i actually
and now that i think about it it's very
rare that i've done it but and the times
that i have it's been pretty great
because like for me really i've only
[ __ ] the next once and never again i
did it once at here
to me it's like the ultimate opportunity
to use a guy for sex because you know
yes you know how to get your way
theoretically yeah you go in in theory
yes you do that to your guy friends that
you okay listen i i backed one of my guy
friends i'll tell you afterwards we
probably all banged them um probably it
was so disappointing yeah it was so
disappointing this is the take back the
night didn't make me come i was so
annoyed
so i hooked up with my friend who he you
know like wore me down over he didn't
make you come
yeah so many male comics haven't made me
come actually every now and then yeah
i've had a lot except one comic um i
want to go through the list really i
feel like comics have actually made
that
one comic did that mm-hmm i'm trying to
think
and then it was just he was so like fake
and like porn star i don't know it was
just like it felt disrespectful i'm like
i'm your friend i know your parents
names
right like like be real like i'm a
hippie i like to be like really open
when i [ __ ] it just felt like how how
how how are hippies open when they [ __ ]
like i like to have like a connection
like a heart connect and
you like to feel like another person
yeah yeah like and it's not you know and
i'm like i'm not going to betray you and
like catch feelings or anything
you need to betray yourself yeah are you
saying he just like wasn't being himself
he wasn't in the moment he was like
putting on a show i just was like
insulted but
yeah yeah yeah i've had sex like that
where you're like you weren't even there
the whole time yeah i love to put on the
show during sex i get all my stuffed
animals and i
do a little tap dance and then you put
them beside you
wait when you ride the deed you guys i
just found out that i've been doing it
well wrong in quotes i like go full on
squad up and down
balls of my heels um but like that is
fun yeah but do you allow
do you come out of him completely
because there's a date
self-esteem yeah yeah is it like one of
those flares you have to crack yes for
them to light it up yes yes
it's a glow oh my god if you break the
guys dick it glows yeah
that'd be funny
there's nothing like okay about a sex
position that requires my feet on the
ground like that gives you more control
but that's because i'm just
gonna show you how i'm on the ground
there's like dangling off seats i don't
do i yeah i don't do that that's like a
squatty thing you know why because
you have very loose achilles is why so
you're able to do the deep asian squat
which is what i can do yeah i can i like
hang out like this
because you're actually working out when
you're having sex i'm very lazy so it's
a whole like it's front like this no but
that's a good one that's good but i
never exert that much
are you okay
yeah he's perfectly fine it's almost
like nothing happens
what that could be
[Laughter]
um
but yeah that's that's real real effort
and i think that's why your your um
backside is very very um
well-formed thanks yeah yeah it could be
like but it could be the the ass could
have come before the squats oh yeah yeah
or the squats
you know i think yeah the ass was there
and then i got a hold of a squat rack
and get the [ __ ] out now you know now
you have a mission
one of my favorite uh memories it that
i've had i think in my life when that
nail fell off shut up
i'm horrified [ __ ] was rich you
they were busy i went to fix it i have
to go back later today when i was at a
strip club with you right and you and
she wore a winter we have fun
corrine was me she was making it rain
and she was buying lap dance after lap
dance for her younger boyfriend and it
was so fun and hot you were just like
chilling confident
mommy warbucks baby yeah it was so hot
can i just make it actually true your
eyes are lit up
so joyful right now this is esther's
dream podcast is those three and we're
just disappointing her left and right
never gone to a strip club
yeah brought it up every day
well we went because esther requested it
and i was like oh i can make that happen
because there is actually a strip club i
like going to a lot in new york that we
had been going to and i was like perfect
timing we go to sapphire a lot there's
two patients but yeah we like i know
like you know people who dance there so
it's a fun time but does that like turn
you on to watch
um it doesn't like turn me on it doesn't
turn me off i just it was his it was
like his first time it wasn't like it
was his first time at a strip club and i
wanted him to have a good time because
all my other girlfriends were like what
are you doing and i was like what am i
gonna do like be like don't look at any
other ladies at this first time at a
strip club that would be psychotic it
doesn't work yeah oh that's cute yeah
24.
i don't know no i was surprised too it
seemed like i would by 24 i had been to
multiple strip clubs so i don't know but
it's the same thing for me with food
it's like i never say like you can't
ever have a cinnamon roll again because
carlos does
does carlos tell you to not go into this
no like you wanna you don't wanna have
something be a naughty temptation for a
guy that's my own temptations in this
relationship i remember christa was
saying his wife like lets him that jazzy
lets him it was like you can do whatever
you want on the road he's like now i
never have any interest well esther
perel talks about like the other like
the the significance of the other sophie
so that makes cause when you mold into
one person when you date for so long and
you're like one person and you don't
want to [ __ ] anymore that's why because
you you're one unit you have to be
separate and in order to keep that
separateness you play with you either
flirt with like oh is are you gonna oh
that shirt's very sexy like a lot of
women are going to hate on you tonight
or something like you play with this
idea of like another person i love where
i never
i love when girls hit on my boyfriends i
do too it's my favorite i've only had
i'm it's interesting that i've cheated i
never ruined my they've never ruined my
ability to watch my boyfriend flirt
flirted with
are you exploring this i think that i am
you should try it in your dirty talk
first that's like the best way to ease
in um so i've always like every
boyfriend i've ever had i've always sort
of like edged with myself where i'm like
but i've never really gone there fully
it's so fun and i really would like to
like i have broached the subject with
bobby and he's just um
like we might have given each other hall
passes in the past but we've never i've
never been a [ __ ] i've never watched him
do anything who would you rather watch
me or esther banging bobby
um
you have to tell the truth
we're right here
probably i would i would be can i answer
can i just i would be lifting him up
oh yeah it because
yeah
i i just like that he would have to
climb you yeah esther and him are too
similar inside i also think he's so
repulsed by me
like because i i he looks at me and he
turns you on he looks at me and he sees
himself right oh my god yes and i think
you're like an exotic
like asian men keep being compared to
you on this show
an old gay asian male murderer
i want to know about your [ __ ]
experience yeah well so my ex-boyfriend
and i would take girls out on dates
okay yeah and we would say how do you
tell them do they the does the girls on
the app it's on a three-way app called
now it's called field what is what was
it called before surrender it was
grinder yes i know it's the same app so
everybody automatically on that app is
cool like they're just if it's a kinky
sexual type of like environment yeah
everybody's really like hey this is what
i like this is what i don't like like
does that work for you and it's very
very upfront very transactional but not
in a not hot way like they're like a
surrogate they're like a surrogate for
your guys kind of
can you meet a surrogate on there
well
we want to [ __ ] the [ __ ] our kid's
going to be trying to get outside
i want to see how much it stretches
esther just learned what fisting is
exciting
oh yeah i did too for
the video we watched last week was a
girl punching into her ass
i would love to not revisit this talk we
we have such a great i would like to
have you bend over and
revisit the
the action when it comes to the cuck
situation do you like just watching him
like how does it usually go down like
what is your ultimate like oh i love
that yeah
all i knew was it was the porn i watched
and it was what i fantasized about when
i masturbated and then we incorporated
it into our dirty talk over the course
of
i would say three years it went from
talking about it for the first time to
actually taking girls out on dates i
feel like it's too healthy the way
you're doing it it was pretty healthy
and it was lovely yeah it was so hot
some of the hottest sex i've ever had my
life wait tell us more details like like
this girl like i was on like i was
laying down and this like gor i remember
in toronto
um
this gorgeous girl like she was on top
of me uh and then he was [ __ ] her
from behind and i was like this is just
the best i'm just going to keep this in
my spank bang for them i would be like
this i would be like
you guys well the first time it was
awkward the first time we did it with
this one uh girl it was just very
uncomfortable and she was really good at
sucking his dick in a way that i was
like
did you take that did you take that did
you take that i did i said i said i'm
less and i don't know what to do right
now but that's also what turns me on
about it this is very conflicting um but
after i came i was like did she suck
your dick better than me
and he was like well it's different i'm
like it's different like she doesn't use
her teeth you dumb [ __ ]
loser wait but i thought see that's what
gets me off is the fact that i'm
threatened and jealous it's very fun to
play with like when you're a kid when
you play pretend you're playing pretend
like you're playing wait yeah what
you're scared of yeah i was like first
of all i'm
yeah if you're [ __ ] bobby and i think
it's already out from the corner
so i'm worried about my breath i'm like
this is before we have bobby okay
i'm like
i'm like how can such a short man be
hold so much
weight and then
he's rolling around you know like a boso
ball on me
and then i'm like oh and then kalila's
there like with like a [ __ ] spearfish
thing she's getting ready to kill her
she's a fish murderer
i want to be the orchestrator like you
have to you're the you're the one who
calls the shots okay
wait now i like it
sewing strings in people
my mouth shut like
i gotta cut it open to put bobby's dick
in here you can have sex with my
boyfriend but i'm managing the strength
it's gonna be like saw have you seen
that
have you seen hostel
because i have been with um two men i
was in a relationship with two men but
that was so difficult at the same time
at the same time are you actually oh
yeah that sounds fun
i wouldn't say that we call her dating
like two and a half men
um i was in a polyamorous relationship
but i don't think that is something that
like it was very emotionally exhausting
yeah sexually fun sometimes but that's
such a small percentage of the
relationship so as the years went on it
was just
very very um
how many how much laundry can i fold
jesus
is they did they want more of your
attention than what they got um it they
did get they weren't close
so it was very um
you know in in any other world they
would not be friends in fact when their
relationship was over they did not keep
in touch
yes yes but also
no because you know there was jealousy
there was things like that involved did
they do you guys should have a reunion
yeah oh this show wait we should
honestly should i call him he's still
one of my best friends which one would
you call oh
we can only three-way call them
okay we're not doing these hacks yeah we
have to be
i wanted to say
did they ever like when when one of them
was banging and the other one came to
get you were they like esther when
carlos took the cupcake
no it wasn't always like that but one of
them would wouldn't last as long as the
other and then he would then cry [ __ ]
you at the same time at the same time
wow all the time not all the time oh
that's so funny now does that appeal to
you yeah i've done that
i've done two guys yeah oh my god we
flew a guy
i got stories i want a new story
out from l.a so the guys kisses no no
wait can you say which part i would like
to say
a lovely guy yeah wonderful like great
dick oh my god ryan what is it ryan
driller driller you flew him somewhere
in a guy threw him out
he is gorgeous banged the crap out of me
was the other guy
did they do stuff no it was just they
kind of have like a thing that like the
other guy like wanted to see me get
[ __ ] like yeah that was a turn on for
him and we were gonna do it we were
gonna do it with a girl next but then we
didn't get that phone
oh the girl oh esther's coming oh i
wanna call you look at what her face is
getting she's silent coming no this is
really interesting stuff
[Music]
i'm so happy that i finally found a
deodorant i love with natives so are we
yeah i guess it's better than more
thrilled
they've got really nice flavors this
little do you call them flavors scents
scents i mean if you're eating it that's
up to you they do you know what they
smell like they would be tasty i would
like i'll do it on the live okay the
live stream i'll lick your arms my
particular the one that i use is the
lavender rose and i'm telling you guys
coming from someone who sweats a lot in
my underarms you would think that i
would be putting off certain aromas but
because of native i smell
so pretty they're best known for their
aluminum-free deodorant and native wants
you to help you practice safe sweats
which is why they keep their ingredients
list bare naked with ingredients that
you understand like coconut oil shea
butter and baking soda these are things
they're not like toxic chemicals like
most deodorants well and i'm very
excited for my live stream challenge
because native has recently partnered
with baked by melissa with a collection
of scents inspired by
baked by melissa's delicious cupcake
creations so i can do tie-dyed vanilla
cupcake
mint cookie cupcake
fresh peach
emoji cupcake i need these
ginger lemonade cupcakes that's that's
me that's that screams me i want a smell
no ginger lemon
cupcake i obviously want tie-dye vanilla
right now
um you guys can smell and feel fresh all
day long with native get 20 off your
first order by going to nativedio.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout that's nativedeo.com
tuesday or use promo code tuesday at
checkout for 20 off your first order
i don't think i've ever seen dave as
happy as when i got him a box of bright
cellars how about when you told him
you're going out of town
like he just lit up yeah he was so
excited by the wine choices and now he
is a true wine lover and this was
basically the best gift i've given him
in 10 years well it's great we don't
drink so we're not gonna be able to pick
out the right wine for people so to have
them do that for you is like you get to
look like a pimp they do all the hard
work for you yeah they basically educate
you on what to pair with certain wines
what you know
flavor profiles what notes to look out
for and i think that it's sort of like
you can be a sommelier yeah after a
couple of boxes of semi
and um i think what i do at least is
because i never like to go to people's
homes empty-handed so for me i keep a
box in my pantry and anywhere any party
i have to go to i always have a bottle
ready i never like to leave empty-handed
yeah i will just grab that right from
your cellar i like to bring an empty bag
yeah fill it up put your wine in there
and then take it to my next party
what i really enjoyed was it asked me
questions about the person's palette so
obviously if you're doing it for
yourself that's easy but i did it for
dave so i know he likes milk chocolate
versus dark chocolate so i answered all
these questions and now he has
personalized wines handpicked by experts
accustomed to his taste i can't believe
he likes milk chocolate but we'll talk
about that later that's wild you guys
can get 50 off your first six bottle box
50 off half off that's half off people
don't know math that's 55
plus taxes and bright sellers is the
monthly wine club that matches you with
wine that you'll love so get started by
taking the taste palette quiz to see
your personalized matches bright sellers
is giving our followers 50
off their first six bottle box that's
six bottles for just fifty five dollars
you guys
that's six bottles for just fifty five
dollars crazy values under ten dollars
each follow the link to take the quiz
and get started today
[Music]
uh look at where okay so i got tristan
taramino who's a porn star she wrote a
book on she wrote a lot of books on sex
um she i went to a class of hers uh at
pleasure chest in new york city and she
recommended something that i was like oh
and i did it and i was like oh that's a
good tip bedroom high heels so you have
a pair of high heels that you only wear
in bed so either like you don't have to
worry about it has those so she can get
into the bed
that's a bedroom ladder
uh i did that uh which i guess isn't
really role play but it like made me
feel different no that's cool like i
like that part of role playing the
weirdest role play i ever did i was
trying to scan through my brain was um a
christmas elf
so you might be into that oh you are
cute kind of elf like yeah well i was an
elf at macy's santa land when i was in
college are you serious yeah because i
was doing research for my thesis film
which is a documentary about the myth of
santa claus sorry to break that to you
on that podcast
no she's jewish she was the kid breaking
it to us don't worry
oh my god
i'll never forget you this may sound
like a shocker but i write to santa
every year still that's very hard that's
not no when i saw you sucking your thumb
on the plane watching a cartoon i said
yes this [ __ ] writes to santa it was
anime anime's very adult theme it is
yeah you try to talk she's like
she's like they're about to bang
did you watch the documentary on playing
the dear santa they have it on delta
flight you have never you have to and
you should become a volunteer i want to
do this you can become a volunteer and
to help the kids that get
you respond to the kids it's a us postal
service run thing and volunteers from
all over the world reply to letters to
santa do you ever put your hand on
you're like yeah
i want to teach you about squirting
listen to you guys
you want to hear
about the guys i've had no but i corrine
i don't want to respond as santa i want
santa to respond okay
it's been 37 years
esther i know
hot though like the movie was a bad
santa like
my friend was banging john reese the guy
who played um uncle rico they were doing
the astronaut farmer in santa fe i used
to live there and so we were on set and
i was in the craft services truck and
billy bob comes on and he goes billy
bob's an international superstar
and um and then and i went okay and then
i was like i can't give this to you sir
this is gonna be hard and then he said
um can i ask you a question i said what
and he goes is three inches too small
and i said it depends on which way
you're holding the ruler which i thought
was so good
and um and he's and then he said do you
know any virgins and i said yes he said
can i meet them and i said absolutely
not
and that was my and then john's like i
could hook you up with him if you want
to go he asked you for virgins yeah it
was all within like it was like a it was
like
like he said
international superstar three inches
virgins and i was like you are being
very billy bob thornton this is exactly
what i thought it would be oh my god but
he was just having fun on a craft
services he was just eating some did you
did you find him to be hot
no okay i was more like i [ __ ] the
crew
the crew is always hotter though i was
like let me massage that one shoulder
you've been holding the camera on yeah
those are the hot guys yeah that was my
lift
but so you did elf role play yeah yeah
what role play do you do esther
if it's not elf you're really missing
there's a whole
i also i want to like go back and say i
don't do alfred
i want to come out
are you do you ever just like candy cane
yourself oh no that actually sounds like
a good idea but doesn't it mint would be
refreshing well i've been doing a joke
about how i like forget my yoni crystal
and so i put in a watermelon jolly
rancher instead
and then i keep thinking like that's
actually like a good idea it's like a
mystery flavor for guys but then i was
like do we get a yeast infection
immediately yes okay i would pure sugar
because then you're like mystery flavor
and then a week later you're like it the
mystery flavor is fish fillet medication
i've got bibi
you guys are destroying christmas for me
it's a very special time of year oh my
god you're sounds so this is the most
molested you always have melissa this is
the most important
honestly we are not preserving christmas
for you let me tell you you're almost 40
[ __ ] okay we're not preserving
christmas christmas is off limits you
guys don't touch christmas it's a pure
heart place do you think your christmas
obsession has something to do with your
father being like a white older man um
well my dad would go through
my dad would christmas is just a very
big to-do so he would have us write our
letters and then what he would do is he
would hire my uncles or anyone around
town to make the noises at midnight
santa sleigh
yeah right he did the red deer something
on the roof i had your footprints on
[Applause]
we'll do it for you this year
yeah it's so scary
[Laughter]
so what my parents would do is they
would say you know go to bed it's nine
o'clock and then when christmas hits at
midnight you would start to hear the
noises in the roof and all of the kids
would be slumbered together in the same
room and you're like oh my god i think
is is that what i think it is
and then they're like santa's here and
all the kids rush out of the room and we
go down the stairs and then my dad would
like leave hula hoops on a tree like oh
you must have forgotten oh i don't know
why i imagine you guys are the ones
making the toys in the philippines you
get christmas
i thought you made our toys that too yes
i thought
you know i'll say something about that
when i first came to america in 98 i was
obsessed with fubu jackets
so i would
but here's how the disillusionment with
america started
is when i finally saved up enough money
to buy a fubu jacket and i went to the
pasadena mall i picked it up i was like
oh dear god like the music was playing
as i approached the table with a jacket
in your head it was a jagged edge
and so i finally picked it up and then i
saw made in the philippines and fubu
meant for us by us right so i thought it
was the most american thing i could
purchase
oh and then when i looked at it i was
like
probably made this
yeah it was really for us
it was for you by you but like
i stand by myself
i want us to get tommy girl like i want
to have like a short mommy girl
yeah i want some polo sport just like
sprayed on me oh i have a pair of booboo
pants that i just i'm just talking about
this
yeah look annie we should bring it back
i think it's coming back it's been yeah
yeah yeah i'm on board with that yes
guys i'm vibrating
[Laughter]
i feel like parents sort of set us up
for failure in that way i'm still on the
santa thing guys that's why i made that
documentary because it literally crushed
my soul when i got outside i wasn't
realizing i made my mind
boyfriend you keep searching for maybe
well here's my thing it's like they just
never told you
i i don't know how they bro if they
actually told you he wasn't real but for
me it was just like left in the open so
here i am 37 still writing letters right
right because i still kind of want to
hang on to something but yeah um i think
that um you're right like it's kind of
this like
trauma in its own way you're like oh
[ __ ] the fantasy bubble has burst yeah i
talked to a child psychologist in the
documentary i talked to a a priest in
the documentary and a lot of people had
different thoughts because there are
like if you remember like the uh mara
wilson version of miracle on 34th street
uh that's kind of part of the the plot
line is that she's like this very adult
child and her parents are very open with
her that santa doesn't exist so it's
even more magical when in the film he
does uh but i always i always was
interested in the parents who raised
their kids like mara wilson because
those kids were weird too you know like
adult children yeah born and raised in
manhattan and exactly born and raised in
manhattan is exactly it yeah see i i
would not want to lie to my children i
think it wouldn't either my
take on it would be like this is a
make-believe story we're pretending it's
real but like there is saint nicholas is
a is a figure a true historical figure
so i think if you connect it to the
history it's not or at the end by the
time they're old enough to be like you
gotta tell them just say santa's in your
heart but you also you need magic in
life and i think like too much honesty
with kids is also a problem you know i
agree
christmas is fun lie to them yeah and
they're gonna get lied to life i feel
like it's like i think religion should
all be the same way it's like when the
kids ate you just go like yeah
religion's the same [ __ ] like it's
not you don't have to
we made it up it's like you got the
morals you got the you learned the
lessons
lie to thy neighbor at eight god isn't
real
yeah i feel like yeah there are more
destructive lies or even that like
you're definitely going to find this
like person who's your soul mate oh i
know but then it happened you could
though
you couldn't find your body but to
constantly wait for that i think it's
destructive to women especially so
well the bachelor sort of proves that
right that whole idea of a soulmate like
you could just like you could fall in
love with so many different people and
have intense connections in so many ways
so it's like it's just really what you
know direction you you ultimately choose
but it's just listen who's gonna like
for me it's like who's gonna do your
laundry who's gonna does your boyfriend
do your laundry yes that's incredible
you found the one no he's a yeah no he's
a helper yeah cause you have a much
younger boyfriend too right oh yeah yeah
do you have a young boy my boyfriend's
24 i'm 36. yeah i'm 30 i'm 38 and my
boyfriend's 27. yeah nice yeah
exactly they're very emotionally in
touch but not after that balance so
we'll get you some boy slugs after you
oh thank you you have a banana
will you deep throat once what part of
the show is
[Music]
i was looking at this tick tock of this
woman who said that the cross section or
the anatomical figure of the clitoris is
omitted from all anatomy textbooks and
so she's trying to sort of overturn
or fix that because if and i can speak
to this because i was an anatomy and
physiology tutor but we don't see you
either yeah for years
number one in long beach what is that
you still are you still the vagina is
but what is your favorite because you
don't learn about the female orgasms you
don't you don't learn about the male 1
because that's and it's especially
important to get the cross
of of or that image because you know you
then know where the nerves sit yeah so
like right um she's and and something
happened to her i'm not sure what
happened to her but
her point was she was taken out
a lot of things happen like vaginal
injuries things of that sort happen to a
lot of women when they're older and
doctors because they didn't have that in
their anatomy books either they sort of
just like um don't like when a woman
gets pregnant or she tears a certain
part of her vagina or a clitoris is
injured they don't really care to kind
of patch it up correctly because they're
not looking after a clitoral pleasure of
women's or not right federal injury is
really dark i mean i ran into a wall on
a bicycle and definitely bruised my
[ __ ] really hard when i was younger and
i thought to myself oh my god like am i
destroyed but i want to know what you
guys think about that and is this the
reason why so many boys either can't
find it don't know what to do with it
don't have the full picture of what that
looks like because they think it's just
this button on top and it's such a full
thing well and also too with sex ed i
don't know about you guys but we got
separated like the first the first oh
your sex head was the girls went in one
where they learned about the periods the
boys went in another room to learn about
boners and so as a result grown men like
missed out on the period no no no no no
my trying to have a lot of sisters you
you're [ __ ] my twin brother and i were
in the same class don't worry
okay
for the sex part we were in the same
class but yeah we were also split for
the periods and i guess
you split up yeah we were we were
straight all together they put up
holding tampons and
i have a kink about dudes removing my
tampons for me what
it's a thing i don't know where it comes
from but i like it i don't take my own
tampons out during never it's always
like you pull it like ever no well like
if we're having sex it's like nobody's
talking about yeah it's part of the
probably being dressed i like when like
some mornings i'll beg dave like please
put my socks on oh my gosh
i'm gonna get you an adult sized
changing table
i'm gonna lift your legs up
and just having a boyfriend you could be
so comfortable with and just like play
with their body and like ask things that
are just like not appropriate
just like kick them in the face like
sometimes i'll make like the penis talk
out of the pizza oh yeah that's fine i
don't like that they don't like that i
like that they don't like it but it's
like that you've all done it so yeah you
know that they don't like that
i've not i've never done that i don't
like making a penis funny because i
don't want it
it's hilarious i i can't even look it's
not
who i knew i was breaking up with him
but he didn't know i was breaking with
him so i knew i was giving him his last
hand job like we were at hand jobs i was
like wow i gave him um turbo jerks in
the shower where like i wouldn't even be
facing him he would be in the shower
i'd be out of the shower like i'm only
wet up to like mid four wow i wanted out
i was like dump me
break up with me and i would give him
the turbo jerks um
and uh
we had just seen blackfish that's why i
would always like do it because i don't
want to turn into a murderer yeah and
make him till it come on his stomach but
then so we so then
he my last hand job when i was like i
got i'm gonna just have to [ __ ] dump
this guy i was three years it was
supposed to be about two months
i was like oh god what am i gonna do
it was such a nightmare so i was like
jerking him off and then i was like i
wonder if i can get in his mouth and so
i was like jerking off in a pretty big
dick and right as he was starting to
seize i just i angled it up and i got it
right in his wow
that's pretty heroic
it was so good i was like
well i i used to tell it on stage like
globetrotters have yeah it was so cool
i know i was like spinning it little
trampoline i was spinning by his boner
like this by the end of it
yeah no it was really cool i was like
really proud of myself but it was evil
because i knew it was this last one
you know that moment where you're like
i'm gonna break up with you yeah i had
that and then there's so much more time
passes before you actually do it we were
on a hike and i was we were in a hike we
were going up the mountain and the sun
was setting and and he like kind of like
dipped me in front of the sun and and
wanted to like kiss me and i felt
nothing yeah he may as well have been
like my aunt you know like yeah i felt
nothing but if but we were and i almost
said something i was like my heart was
beating but we were going up the
mountain and we still had to finish the
hike so if we had been going down i
would have cut
two and a half years out of that
relationship wow
never again i was younger then i say you
have to wait at least a month before you
decide on whether or not that feeling of
ick is real or fleeting i guess so
because it's yeah because it could be
just the day well it was almost out of
me though the snake the obsession snake
had left the building well depending on
where i am in my cycle like when i'm
close to i'm i
there are moments where i really really
hate my partner yeah yeah are you on the
phone
me too when i was on birth control
especially i'm not on it now but um
yeah it i almost felt just so like and i
always would tell myself it's just for a
day or two you don't actually
[Music]
never had a thing where i'm like i don't
like them i have to hold like you test
them too you tested dave i do i will
throw tests for sure anymore yeah at the
beginning yeah in the beginning you kind
of yeah move in or we're done when
you're in your early 20s you know you
you play the game when you're in the
early 20s living in the same room as one
grown woman yes i it was time it came
from
the time i came from rough beginnings
what what so what's is there a reason
that you most likely is there a feedback
that you get consistently from partners
when you get dumb i
i think i'm i don't know no i have never
gotten consistent um like you started to
get too old looking i think it just ends
yeah i don't i can't like remember
you
do you have like little little sister
what do you say i have kid sister
energy and i gotta kill that part of me
when i'm trying to [ __ ] yeah i'm like
are you because that is not [ __ ] or are
you trying to like get a go to the candy
store
but you know what i do relate to that
breakup feeling in friendships like i
recently had a thing where i was like oh
once you click that it's over like
and you sell yourself on the idea and
you're like it's over yeah yeah and
someone was was telling me that's very
much like an ex-boyfriend thing
and so i know that feeling when you're
like it's enough
it's done and there's nothing you can
say or do to like
come back it ran its course yeah well
have you been friend dumped too like
when you get friend dumped you get
you're like so hurt for a while but then
when you just release and you you look
back on it you go oh thank god it's
always a gift i love friend dumpling oh
really it's amazing it's a lot harder in
my opinion than a romantic breakup
because you can't blame like sex yeah
but it's just like i don't like
necessary
yeah it's i don't want to hang out it's
it's i just learned this year how to do
it and it's like it's amazing i just
block them and don't talk to them i did
so many over quarantine like there's so
many people that i cut out you formally
cut them out or were you just like some
formally some not but it felt it's just
like i felt so much lighter like i was
like there's no energy when you friend
them do you have to announce it to that
person or can you just you can or you
can't it doesn't matter like there's it
depends i think it depends like what the
level your friendship was
how that person responds to you pulling
away some people will directly ask and
like if you're you know gonna ask me
i'll give you an answer that's how i
feel but i don't think everyone needs
like like also to give to give feedback
to someone who's not your romantic
partner because the romantic partner i
think deserves feedback because you're
the only per partner but friends like
you're you know that's assuming that the
person has multiple friends and you're
not leaving them friendless right uh and
it's almost like well who the [ __ ] asks
for my feedback on why they're not a
good friend they're just not a good
friend for me yeah anymore it's kind of
what you were saying about like sex
because we've had we've had sex with the
same people and had very different
experiences yeah very different
sometimes you don't know that until
you're both naked
or whatever the [ __ ] this is it's not
and sometimes you just have to scratch
the itch to realize there was nothing
there yeah i back to friend breakups
like i
i
feel
because i can't ever really break up
with someone so in my head a friend
breakup is something it's more of a
pause it's a shell thing like that's
what i like to see it asks like
yeah yeah wait there might be another
time where it might be better for us
yeah
back together with a friend who i had a
very big friend break up with did it
work out yeah but it's not this it's not
certainly didn't come back to the level
that i was at but also she lives in a
different state now so it's not possible
but you know it was nice to
talk about it and you know be like yeah
that we needed to not be friends for a
while you know when you get to become
enemies like esther and i got in a fight
oh yeah like 10 years ago we had like a
whoa we had like three members
yeah it's hard it almost is like hard to
remember now but you know when you're
kind of like talking [ __ ] on each other
but i don't know i don't count that as
an official friend breakup because we
were so young and silly it was like
exactly an incident happened and then we
just took a beat a friend break up to me
and it's like so funny it's like someone
that's like integrated into your life
right and then it's like yeah this is
needs uh when you're working when you're
growing up like i look at it like
i need people that are either this is
how i look at my friends you're either
making me laugh or you're a therapist of
some sort
like direction upward like i talk to
bonnie mcfarlane every day and i will
never stop but it's like it's like we
laugh all the time but also are working
on ourselves so it's like there's two
things that i love happening those are
good pillars that's the best yeah but
like i think about i had a friend who
was and she was a really sweet girl i
had i had to stop talking to her because
she was pulling me out of my life like
she wanted to throw me a surprise party
for my birthday and it's like every day
is my birthday but you're not a comedian
so you don't like understand that so
whatever you're planning for me would
actually it would instead of having 365
days of birthday i would have 364 days
of birthday and i would then be doing
some boring [ __ ] where you're actually
just trying to meet my famous friends is
that what you said to her
no i just stopped talking to her forever
nice i just got too busy because i am
too busy like it really is like i'm too
busy to be invited to like these events
i don't want to go to that have nothing
to do with like me and well you know to
suffer when i grow up i'm growing up
a million times why are you still even
asking yeah yeah yeah and you realize oh
i don't have to do everything that
people say
i think it's a great lesson to learn not
going to a party oh amazing that's a
good example of like a good boundary
because it's like
it is so easy in a friendship to get
wrapped up and feel like you have to go
to this thing or how i have to do this
because you asked me your default is yes
and then you starting yourself and then
it builds up and you're like wait
i don't want to do those things what is
this like i'm doing things i don't want
to do right now yes i'm on a vacation i
was like in like another country like
why am i here i don't want to be here
yeah you get carried away with it
because you don't realize that you're
just yes yes yes well you know what
happened
i can't even talk about it i do feel
like
there it just there comes a time where i
realized it was a low self-esteem on my
end because i was looking to another
like i like she would go let's go on
this vacation i go oh that's not like my
style at all i would not want to go
there and she goes no you just haven't
tried it trust me and i'm like right so
then i'd be like maybe i'm wrong and
then i'm there and i'm like trying to
talk myself into like in this [ __ ]
terrible vacation and i'm like i could
just be with my boyfriend and my dog
like why am i here right yeah i don't
you know i have fun at the dmv like i
don't have to go
right if i'm gonna go i've seen it it's
gonna be nice
i love it it's enjoyable i need you um
soon to go back to the dmv with me
because it would be an honor my niece
jules set me up for [ __ ] failure my
new dmv picture is horrendous yeah and
they wouldn't let me redo it on the spot
because that is it yeah beckham tries to
redo it on the spot and even they
wouldn't let her do it right no i don't
like that we have a posh coming in and
threatening my posh
oh wait are you possible she's not
pissed
newsletter for years danny but here's
the thing
she wants she flew i mean english you're
obviously posh my my commitment to the
spicy girls is life long and heavy
no matter what you say right i don't
care what evidence you have saying that
i'm not posh i'm [ __ ] posh posh comes
from with inside do you think right
right it's a vibe had he known she was
or she was posh would he have given her
a second chance because people just go
through the dmv looking pretty like no
they knew because it was a fur it was
for a documentary so
yeah yeah
obviously there was performatives also
yeah
when i first moved to l.a and i was a
babysitter for a wealthy family we i
remember we did the morning drop off it
was me and the mom and victoria beckham
i love that wait i was there keep going
you had to do the morning drop off with
the yeah i was always a mommy's
assistant
i was always like just the sidekick but
we saw victoria beckham and the mom that
i was working for was like ah is she
skinnier than me i was like yes i'm
victoria yes 100 if she isn't you're
dead yeah
you are in the ground you're a corpse
just you died a while ago
it's been a long time one of my favorite
stories about
victoria beckham is that her mom trolled
her one time by making her a birthday
cake but it was a sculptured cake and it
was like grapes and like a bottle of
water because she never ate and i was
like perhaps you gave your daughter an
eating disorder perhaps
mrs adams but okay
she's like your mom esther i think she
only gained like eight pounds during
pregnancy yeah my mom says nine pounds i
think i was just the baby nothing just a
baby i was talking to someone who was
saying his girlfriend is
uh has eating disorders and then
mentioned that her mom was a dietitian i
go oh that's why she's eating disorder
yeah right no no no no she has eating
disorders and the mom was a dietitian i
went no
i was like boys are so dumb yeah they
are that's the exact reason exactly oh
we don't go into the origin no we we're
women we go into the origin story okay
we know exactly where it came from yeah
yeah
anyways you guys thank you so much for
being here everyone should listen to
guys we [ __ ] up
talk make it stop your podcast
which is available
on luminary but it's also available now
yeah wide run it's wide release now
everyone can listen to it and we can do
another one tomorrow yes i like this one
yeah this is fine i think you guys are
pioneers and i forever bow down to you
both and thank you for doing this some
people think we paid you i know thanks a
lot it's so nice we don't know how to
take all these compliments you know that
my niece my my 20 year old niece she
doesn't listen to us she listens to them
you guys thank you
thank you for watching check out guys we
[ __ ] check out their special on
youtube our special day we'll see you
next week and subscribe to this channel
because we need it or annie's gonna beat
me
[Music]
[Music]
you